onze gardes allemands mahatma mangé
personne et surtout tu m'emmerdes
pareils
tu fais qui peuvent être sonné mais
c'est même plus comment elle s'appelle
point net a les joues alzheimer il faut
pas faire de tous les étrangers les
boucs émissaires dont votre malheur je
parle là pour vous permettre east vous
mériteriez vraiment d'être blanc je veux
bien saisir vos biens à tarbes autres
mais vous pouvez pas me faire ça avec le
minimum vieillesse pour vivre tout est
là 3
c'est ma belle-mère un peu spécial c'est
mamie paulette
site inquiète malice et de la bonne
performance
je j'ai la base du commerce
je vends des bateaux saint-élie
travaille plus pour aider plus je vous
file 10 % sur chaque client que vous me
ramener
sion touche pas drogues dures bien sûr
j'ai l'impression de changer moi qui
n'aimais personne sympathique avec un
petit point
on va élargir le business du bras sa
place surtout pas qu'on va s'écouler
ce que vous transportez la d'emplois
qu'elle a drogué